at these exercises your workouts and
gain much more than just strength and
make your workouts far more exciting and
interesting these are some of the most
awesome and unusual exercises that
you're probably not doing right now I'm
also gonna give you guys a little bit of
an update on some stuff that's been
going on on the channel you might have
noticed I've been away for a couple of
weeks and you might have noticed that
this video isn't about neck training
like I said it was don't worry that's
coming also of course I've just released
my ebook super-functional training which
you can buy on the link down in the
description below so update you on that
as well but first let's get into the
meat let's talk about some of the most
awesome unusual multi-purpose exercises
that you're possibly not doing right now
number one is one of my favorite
exercises that I talked about in my
old-time strongman video and that is the
squatting press not to be confused with
the squat press squat press you squat
and then press dumbbells or a barbell
over your head what's in Crest you hold
the weight on the chest and then you
squat underneath it keeping your arms
still and extending them above you as
you drop lower so the weight stays
exactly motionless no longer are you
pushing the weight away from you now
you're moving around to the weight and
this requires an entirely different kind
of coordination and strength not only
gonna be building massive cost ability
to be able to do this it's also a
mobility test both of your squatting and
for your shoulders because keeping your
arm straight like that's as hard there's
a kind of isometric hold involved ever
at the same time there's also a dynamic
element it's just an incredibly
challenging and interesting and unique
exercise and if you've never done
anything like it before then you're
gonna really feel the difference number
two is the loaded carrier made a whole
video unloaded carries loaded carries
basically mean you're picking up
something really heavy and then you're
walking across the gym down the garden
or even down the street and the idea of
course is that you're moving heavy
object which is an extremely functional
form of training because essentially
you're doing something that you would
actually do in real life carry something
heavy from point A to point B this of
course is a form of resistance cardio
there's a cardio element you're gonna
burn some fat you will so building
muscle moreover you also building more
stability you're gonna build strength in
the hips and in the core and you can be
able to balance an off set weight
especially if you use suitcase carries
where you're carrying the weight on just
one side or if you're using overhead
carries where you keep your arms
extended over your shoulders either
these things it's really going to
improve your balance in your core and
this can make you almost impossible to
push over you can also correct errors in
your gait to make your walking better
and of course this also trains the traps
and it trains for grip whilst you're
walking you should attempt to keep your
traps slightly engaged so that you're
not completely soggy this will help to
build more trap strength this will help
to build more trap strength and also
prevents injury so loaded carries next
up our Pike pulses and this is one you
might not have seen the idea is that you
sit on your butt you lean slightly
forwards keeping your arms legs and back
all straight and then you touch the
ground roughly around your knees or just
in front of them then you're going to
pick the legs up keeping them straight
so you're kind of doing a reverse sit-up
there's a strange exercise and you won't
go to lift your legs all that high and
that's kind of the point here this of
course is a core abs workout but more
important it builds compressive strength
or compression strength this is your
ability to compress your own body so
when you lack mobility so you lack the
ability to touch your own toes or the
pancake or to perform the awesome manner
exercise this often isn't just because
you lack the flexibility it can actually
be because you lack strength because you
need to push against your own body your
own hips and you're in core so training
this kind of compressive strength can
improve your mobility significantly and
that'll help you to build up cooler
moves like the V sit next calf jumps I
like calf jumps so much that I almost
made a whole video about them I almost
wrote a song about the calf jumps
basically involve keeping the legs
entirely straight and then jumping by
just pushing through your toes
explosively so to basically a jump we
are keeping all the joints except for
your
your ankles completely straight so what
you're basically doing here is isolating
the carbs involvement in jumping and
thereby you can train a specific part of
your jump performance that might be the
weak link as it were it can improve your
running speed and it can improve your
jump height and training curves is
really boring and anything that's done
in a bit weird is okay in my book you
can also try doing off one leg if you
wanna increase the challenge a little
bit and what I recommend is as you land
you're going to soften you're going to
slow down your landing by landing back
on your tiptoes and then doing a kind of
slower eccentric this prevents a jolt in
your knees and it also adds a small
eccentric element next up a rope climbs
I'm not gonna go into them in huge
detail here because I've already talked
about them loads I post these of myself
doing them all the time but rope
climbing is something you can easily do
at home many people don't realize this
by tying a rope around a pull-up bar for
instance and it builds grip strength it
builds core strength of course your lats
and biceps it's a great way to build
towards a one-arm pull-up and there's
also lots of variations that you can do
that lots of people don't realize say
for instance you put your legs against
the wall and do a kind of rope wall
climb or you can try and do bodyweight
rows this way for your leg against the
wall hold onto the rope and then row
just your upper body you can then trying
do this with one hand you can do all
kind of different again ways to increase
the challenge by using a weighted vest
or by trying to climb faster or for
longer it's just a really versatile and
fun way to train that really builds
pretty much everything is fantastic next
up are pistol squats pistol squats
basically involves squatting down to the
ground on one foot keeping your heel
flat on the floor these are fantastic
for building mobility because a lot of
people can't squat all the way down you
kind of have to go ATG when you're doing
the pistol squat they're also great for
a building balance and for training
single leg strength again I made a video
on that training a single leg at a time
has a lot of benefits and they're really
good for training your legs and the
thing about training the legs is it's
really hard to do with just bodyweight
pistol squats are one of the only ways
to really challenge yourself you know
with a high level of difficulty for just
a few reps when you're only using
bodyweight to train your legs and at the
same time again you can mix this up
and more difficult by holding a weight
lost you do it or perhaps by exploding
up from doing pistol squat jumps there's
lots of options it's fantastic exercise
to have in your arsenal you can do it
anywhere and the last one I'm going to
end on is rock climbing so rock climbing
is a bit of a curveball here because
it's not an exercise as such it's more
of a whole sport but if you incorporate
rock climbing into your workouts you're
gonna see amazing benefits across the
board
rock climbing builds your grip strength
to an insane degree or forearms it feels
laps they even build your legs more so
than people realize it's strategic and
of course it's a huge element of cardio
and you're gripping on to the face of a
cliff or you know bouldering wall and
you don't a fall you're gonna be holding
on for dear life even as you're
completely running out of energy and you
can't hold on any longer it's a
fantastic workout for your brain and
your body and I really loved it and I
could keep going on and on and on just
ask my wife but that'll probably do for
now let me know in the comments down
below what some of your favorites are
and perhaps I'll make a part 2 in future
if you'd like to see that and before I
leave I did say that I had some updates
and I was gonna let you in on what's
been going on over at the Pioneer so
like I say I've been away for a little
while I've had three weeks off which is
quite a long time for the Pioneer don't
worry it's not going to happen again and
I will be doing the neck training video
next and the reason it happened of
course is that I've been working on the
e-book which I'm extremely proud of but
unfortunately I had a lot of other stuff
unexpected going on in my life had two
deaths close to me very sadly I had a
business trip to San Jose which was kind
of last-minute thought I could work on
the plane turned out there's no Wi-Fi
and it was a terrible plane with no leg
room and not even any aircon not
impressed that was British Airways by
the way and yeah I hurt my finger as you
guys saw which isn't great for typing
and I'm a writer by trade so that was
really good and then the course that I'm
doing the company went into liquidation
so that was fun to chase around it's
just been a crazy month and a half and
of course I have to finish the book that
has to be the priority and unfortunately
then I couldn't do much here if you
pre-ordered the book and haven't
received it yet then please let me know
write to me at Adam at the bio near comm
you should have received it by now if
you haven't
yeah there are some problems with the
WooCommerce confirmation thing which
basically meant our staying up to till
about 3:00 a.m. last night and the my
baby got me up at 6:00 a.m. which was
actually quite good but I was working up
until 2:00 a.m. the night before meant I
didn't really have the energy to do a
big video on neck training I just wanted
to run down something like a door off
the top of my head I hope you found this
useful and interesting is a video I've
been hoping to do for a while
like a sail be back as usual next week
with the neck training and in fact I'm
going to be doubling down there on the
YouTube channel and the website because
the next goal is to reach that hundred
thousand subscribers so yeah sorry I was
away for a bit won't happen again and
I've got some really cool stuff on the
way I've planned a lot of big heavy
hitters things that people have been
asking for for a while so I think
hopefully you're gonna like it just to
confirm yes the e-book is available
right now so you can go and buy it from
the link in the description down below
or from the website and you'll receive
it instantly it's a huge ebook that goes
over everything pretty much that I've
covered on the site in the past and
combines it at the end into a single
workout program there's lots of extra
materials in there as well as a little
bonuses that's all working perfectly now
so head over there if you're interested
and also a huge thank you to everyone
who's already pre-ordered or bought the
book the support has been overwhelming
and I'm really glad that you guys seem
to be enjoying it so far I'm really
proud of it and I hope you guys find it
useful and interesting as well a lot of
you been asking if there's gonna be a
physical copy there won't be a physical
copy of that exact book because that has
a lot of digital elements to it it's
also very big and if you'll see it's
very stylized it would require an awful
lot of ink can be a lot of money to
print so I'm gonna probably do something
different in the future that will be
physically published I'd like to find a
actual publisher for that like I did for
my two working online and programming
books however I might end up just
publishing some for myself if that
doesn't happen don't wait around for
that if you want to get the digital
version but something in the future will
probably be coming just because you guys
have been really demanding it and asking
for it so that's what's been going on
with the Pioneer that's what's been
going on with me and that's what's been
going on with super functional training
I hope you found this video useful and
interesting and like I say there's lots
of really awesome stuff on the way soon
stay tuned for that and neck training
next thanks a ton for watching guys and
I'll see you next time bye for now